I don't know if you always do them but
like I think the best way they get into
video is just do it
hi I'm riders cry say hi Hey okay all
right
this is go bad are you doing is look in
the sand hmm I'm drinking by the
whatever I don't care okay we're going
okay so the objective of this game is to
find eggs yeah a pretty big they're
pretty big cuz ostrich eggs
art wait hang on I got my ostrich facts
here somewhere where am i Austria facts
what do i US Jews aren't fish apparently
ostriches are not fish that's a fact
ostrich okay all right we found a bug
I'm gonna report it to the developers
fish can fly yep all right there we go
we got to ostrich facts okay I can't get
this one it's too high Oh can we do our
flying technique all right I don't know
what we did I'm flying a little bit
yeah that's not flying that's like
hovering oh you stood on my head thank
you very much you're welcome
oh my god cry your butt is like so big
I'm trying to look at it's not work
hey there we go game of the year 11 out
of 10 at 10
whatever call it says your chest wait
hang on it there's a sign here
yeah Milligan it took there's nothing in
here no hang on try to kick everything
with yeah or mouse - no master - is jump
no their own control there we go okay
hang on wait it's mass three oh there's
balls
oh boy my favorite those are those like
$0.25 ones you get in the machines it's
Thor's come on a quarter machine balls I
wanna bouncy balls
they're balls at the mortgage where you
get them in the twenty five seven sheets
okay all right okay all right how'd you
get up oh I got there - bonus activated
double door does that mean no Z or masa
- to kick trees oh I get it
hang on yeah mine was better watch does
not help us no it does check that that's
not gonna work I do not see that what
did you just do
my scream what you're flying in midair
no no that's not happening
you're are nothing you are nothing we
learn the Oscars can fly have we not but
they can't float all right drink to
celebrate I was there was there were
golden eggs I saw it in the movie wait
hang on I'm starting I got we went to
the next time but I go Stern noon
everybody's gonna see my password
go what is the oh my god
Oh No okay whatever just join join join
join join okay man there's a [ __ ] over
there oh my god we gotta go no wait no
no no no you scare it you'll scare it
away I'm gonna kick this know why did
you cuz I went after the fish well I
don't want a pineapple so all right then
my head yeah it's a green head
well if this is the nest to equipment
what what oh you know what I'm out no no
don't go I don't have a hat I didn't get
it
you can't boost me up to get it no fine
I'm gonna find something even better and
just you you're laughing now are you
back yet no I can't get there we go okay
I got out hang on this is a horrible
idea what did they abandon you for the
stupid ass see that's what I was saying
although it was a pretty sweet ad oh it
is it's a valuable lesson though that
people should learn to nod man and
Friends for green hats
exactly exactly very much except on st.
Patrick's Day or something right that
take drink for lessons yes I agree
mm-hmm I got the score you got beat is
90 306 a 3 over Y plays this game that
much I fell I died it hurt bad
I'm sorry I did it I won okay all right
I'm starting up the level go to level 4
I can't well god damn it
all right fine I'm starting up level 2
again sure though we did it already I
have no idea that's why you quit I mean
that yeah
anyway now get down here you you want
the Hat yeah I want that hat there you
go you can get out of that I'm gonna
take that out I'm been on your big butt
there and hey it is pretty big yeah no
idea what you were doing I wanted to be
the pebble that you throw into the lake
and the bounces the father Chester the
butterfly on what's the treasure I don't
know something has changed nearby look
around oh is it the fact that there's a
giant volcano on fire no that's what
we're trying to not die from oh we're
gonna do that we're gonna not die we're
gonna die we're gonna do both we can't
do both I want to think that we can
stupid reset so we can't do I don't
think scooby-doo said that I was giving
you had nothing to do we do in my time
you know I'm gonna [ __ ] say it Velma
was always pretty hot yeah hotter than
Daphne high five high five I I don't
know where you high-fived I high-fived
my web camera yeah you have a look
freaking stupid with me I done this
audio so it sounds like realistic of
whatever whatever I'm just sitting over
here looking stupid screw you
let me see if I can go across that
little floaty thing okay all right no
more drinks all of my options either
cross or depleted when are you still in
the game I can't kidding me
the trees are not able to take me there
gone god dammit
we got new levels to again open that
it's like that one level in Sonic where
you got that marble zone that one level
in Sonic you don't even say which Sonic
game I a first one first what yep recall
back in mine I didn't even have a Sega I
never did it was all I played a Sega but
I never had one oh my god I can't do
this video markiplier I'm sorry it
wasn't my choice
turn here I had a Dreamcast I had a
friend who had a Dreamcast oh you didn't
have a Dreamcast and your judgment are
you joining the game or why trying to
join it's not working it's like knock
knock who's there
get out of the game get out of that come
on try again okay going back in okay is
an hour I didn't say go get out I'm
gonna go all the way out to the main
menu
oh my game crashed I sound bandicam I
have it I do see more I didn't I'm gonna
put on the Hat yeah I don't know why cry
you [ __ ] what have you been doing over
here kick open your wardrobe across the
gun I got it okay alright oh yeah all
right we're gonna do this you ready I
would love to be ready starting up level
2 I really want a hat though oh I know
right yeah so jealous we get this hat
this is the sweetest hat ever in the
history of hats I want to wear that hat
along with you know you got
Shh okay you know what we don't even
need the points let's just go okay just
got the hat that's all we needed
okay all right all right oh no you
kicked the one on the left okay kick the
one on the right cuz apparently they're
different I did it you did it okay good
got it even you know actually I even see
that one over there so I'm gonna take no
time at all why did that take so long
before my list of ostrich facts keep you
boys in this chess I could I was trying
to get to the chest but they wouldn't
let me ladybugs are you breakin I'm
breaking all sorts of stuff valuing
aspects just don't have a museum jaw
mass well maybe if they have hats they
have museums they're multicultural now I
don't think there's no way that's true
there's no way didn't get me in the
water mr. laughy pants now cuz I like
laughing at your antics over there I'm
gonna have to call my lawyers Oh
a person sir oh really really really
don't you well maybe a few maybe
yeah yeah I maybe I want to be the
Grinch er you know what is the grand
dream was thinking wait what you were
the one dying in the ocean don't tell me
you're good at this game you are not
good at this game
I thought about the super Mario levels
and I did that starting next game go way
better okay think I started back up
again how do you put on sunglasses I
can't they my my oh my hat oh it's a
trade-off okay well you have the
sunglasses I'll have that I can't even
put on my sunglasses
then that's stupid I can't even put on
your sunglasses
wait no recording was way off wasn't
even close to capturing the window not
the whole time not the whole time just
that for bandicam I told you Santa can
with stupid Hey properly you just have
something wrong with your you didn't
think bad things really nice and I think
there's something in the middle here let
me just stick my head down no nothing it
was nothing go away it was nothing okay
this looks like Tarak for the antenna 64
oh you're right it does turn except I
never played that game why I don't know
I was a dumb I was dumb I was PC gamer
as a kid even as a kid
what why
stop playing Commander Keen I never
played a problem with my gaming my feet
[Laughter]
I'm going in the rainbow okay like ten
bucks I don't know everybody all right
don't worry about don't be afraid I am
I'm so afraid that's like my job to be
afraid okay God be ballsy now okay got
the ball supply
balls balls applier let's go I don't
think no no it's on a patrol like go if
we go now
it won't come back cuz it's a patrolling
genius hide help me hide with me hi get
us in get real close mechanic is four
holy crap we can't see him he can't see
us
of the year it's just like baby physics
Oh baby because that's how they play
hide and seek they just close your eyes
oh well I don't question get to the game
with you so be alright okay
my head is in the sand alright what you
got you gotta see this hat it's dark in
you're gonna I'm gonna present it
alright you gotta cover your eyes of you
almost cover your eyes okay I'm right
open your eyes it's crazy how that works
out
you're like Michael Jackson in that one
thing I know I have one foot loved over
my foot I think it says rocks you
touched your feet in the last level I'll
avenge you I think you're supposed to
avenge me I think you're just going to
avoid him there's giant pouring lava
here is avenging you
you didn't avenge very good then haha
well yeah I'm going over here what
where's that I don't know I'm on some
pads in an ocean I just jumped down a
pit in one good job oh my god okay
better than Team Fortress 2 in terms of
hats this is better than Team Fortress 2
in terms of engaging gameplay true that
shots fired cry has made it very very
clear how he feels about tf2 okay are
you following me
yeah did you follow me yeah I am why is
it like showing it's like a spotlight I
don't know tweaking me out could tells
you where to jump vote Pedro vote for
Pedro that was Napoleon Dynamite
I got that reference it was very you're
the last one in you fall as they did
there's a Skellington over here - it was
a sledgehammer no that was also a
Napoleon died am i right I also got that
oh you're breaking things yes and the
sound displacements poor because it
sounded like it was right next to me
nervous
Game of the Year that's wait here Oh
what the hell are you there's like four
skeletons don't kill me where in the
world did you find a hat where you died
there was right cries was a hat cried
why you dirty dirty dirty girl
you mean look at that cowboy hat it's
cowboy hey you're gonna have that cowboy
hat now we got to get back though
okay don't die I'll try nothing if you
die I've got one life left I'm okay this
is Bo's shiny thing in it hey we got
sons of eggs oh we need more anymore is
gonna birth Einstein ostrich I know he's
gonna come back that way you got it
no you get he's gonna come around that
would know he's not gonna come around
that way I'm good hey hey good for you
let's jump down the hole we're almost
done with the game oh my god $10 game if
they put guns on these ostriches this
would be pretty amazing I think we could
rob a bank of golden eggs I'm gonna
probably get killed by the skeleton
coming
there's a really bad Patrol yeah they
don't pay attention to where we're going
or what we're doing or who we are
yeah okay hey I hit a thing okay I went
in a circle I know I kind of did too
no it's garlic tied okay I found a lever
down here well put the lever and then do
the thing I think I might die going in
here
do the lever and the thing I might die
nothing good I'm gonna try hiding my
head one the Skellington come to my okay
we got it we got it I'm going for I got
make my way there yeah I'm so great I
got fireworks a mic or screen Oh Katy
Perry's involved in the development of
the games madman and fireworks right out
of her boobs it's more that's so it's
incredible she's right here oh this game
is not raining properly oh I'm gonna
censor it for everyone else it's gonna
look like fireworks to everyone else but
I mean it's really Katie Bears boobs
like right in front of me Oh story yes I
would love to know the story so when I
was little I lived in a house that my
mom swore was haunted hmm so she woke up
one night it was all dark and she's had
this porcelain doll but he swears by
this that its head was spinning rapidly
the whole time while she was sleeping
just like rapid like rapidly spinning
like the whole doll was shaking like a
vibrator well that's the weird thing
okay I found a new skin how'd you find a
new skin I could change my my dialect I
didn't train the new skin anyway yeah
that's a creepy story how did she know
spinning all night if she was asleep I
think
she was scared and light watched it and
there's holes in the ground all right so
the chick this level is a guy put her
head in the ground I don't think that's
the way to go come on come on come on I
know something something is changed what
have you done I don't know it's a moose
I meant to say it's a Moo it's a cow
skin hey no I was are you up there
okay no I was already up there sure you
know sometimes I think I'm right what
the hell have you done I'm scratching up
everything Oh put your personal
belongings
wait there's a rainbow thing I don't
trust it I do can we kick this open no
can you why are we taking the exit not
the giant piles of golden coins well
sometimes I realize life is more
valuable we were doing the thing again
my god
we gotta do that thing again I wanna fly
with you do it so very precise I'm going
up it wasn't high enough alright screw
ya I'm going off all right bye-bye
I can't even see it's very nice this
platformer is taking a strange turn
we're almost done oh we gotta get
another drink drink wait no I got a
bubble on my head what alright you go
this way and I'll go this way too
okay oh my god is she why are our eggs
done here oh there's a shark
it's okay so we just got to not panic
I wasn't even near it oh wait hang on
there's a there's a thingy there's a
thingy well that did portal there's
another ostrich here while you're over
there it's like an imposter you because
there's the same hat what no that's your
personal copy of me you can take that
and go have fun with that later
well go to label Oh French oh yeah and
they get we do for my I actually they
put it on Netflix I watched every
episode again oh I'm in the ocean I
gotta go in the ocean with you I keep
looking over at your doppelganger thank
you I see more bubbles I'm going to get
more bubbles okay I'm trying to figure
out which way you want to see the
bubbles bubble they do Hey I don't think
that's French I see a portal under the
water no I think it's very offensive to
the French I think they're gonna hear
but I don't think the French could kick
them a bit I just go another one's
coming for I write for me if you look
above on the you I killed me
I found a shiny stone man goddamn bubble
god I can't get one myself you have one
on my screen you have one on my screen
so I'm thinking we have one okay this
game was broken I think
cuz we can't beat this I think so
because I just jump to the ocean
I'm totally fine all right that's a good
enough playthrough I guess if you want
to see the last level yeah it's a
goodbye play with your friend
preferably drunk crying a great game
thank you everybody for watching click
the description link for crys channel
cuz he's all do that ok don't do that
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right so what'd you do dig up the
bodies move your hand like so
[Music]
Oh
firmly grasp it